[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs ce jeudi des idées
sorties pour continuer ces vacances de
février tout de suite le sommaire de
cette semaine un week-end une soirée à
deux ou en solo pour la saint valentin
les sites rivalisent d'imagination pour
vous faire passer de bons moments
remonter le temps et découvrez le style
rococo au château de maisons le
mouvement artistique est au coeur d'une
exposition et d'ateliers où les enfants
font parler leur créativité et l'agenda
complet de vos sorties au programme du
sport de l'improvisation et du thé et du
cinéma
ce vendredi c'est la saint valentin
c'est l'occasion de partager un moment
avec sa moitié de nombreux lieux dans
les yvelines rivalisent d'imagination
pour vous proposer soirées et week-ends
et si vous êtes en ce moment célibataire
on pense aussi à vous regarder lorsque
vous aurez choisi votre avis je vous
invite à s'approcher de lui et a soufflé
à souffler votre prénom
touché un arbre pour se reconnecter à la
nature à soi-même se débarrasser de ses
soucis isabelle partage son amour pour
la nature en ce week-end réservé aux
amoureux
elle propose une séance de silves aux
thérapies à bonnel pour être bien pour
gérer son stress
on peut aller dans la nature et profiter
notamment des arbres avec les terpènes
et python side et tous les bienfaits
qu'ils ont naturellement et qui nous
font du bien
une animation précédé d'un repas le
vendredi soir à l'hôtel le bar ouvert en
juin 2018
au menu volaille sauce au vin jaune à
partager nous avons tout de même créé un
menu pour cette fête là et nous allons
plus jouer sur un côté de rôle je dirais
de la fête en question un côté amusant
plus que de l'apprendre de manière très
sérieuse comme elle peut l'être très
commercial à maurepas c'est une soirée
sans valentin qui est proposée petit
love room avec speed dating au programme
et un concert mené par un dj une soirée
réservée à tous
c'est pas réservé aux amoureux on aura
un système de bracelet on donnera des
bracelets roses pour les gens qui sont
célibataires et qui veulent faire des
rencontres et pour celles qui veulent
être tranquilles on donnera d'autres
bracelet tête à tête au coeur de la
nature ou encore autour d'un verre
l'amour se vivra ce week-end avec et
sans modération c'est l'événement volet
de l'année 2020 au vélodrome nationale
la structure accueille du 28 mars
prochain le match par les tours un match
qui sera suivi d'un concert de gaëtan
roussel la billetterie est ouverte et un
tarif spécial est prévu pour les
yvelinois la réduction est valable
exclusivement pour les places en gradins
est disponible à l'accueil du vélodrome
sport aussi du côté de plaisir la ville
elle recherche des bénévoles pour le
départ de paris-nice la course au soleil
démarre cette année de la ville
saint-quentinoise pour une étape le 8
mars prochain
l'occasion de devenir bénévole sur les
preuves en tant que signaleurs les
inscriptions sont ouvertes jusqu'au 16
février un voyage direction le xviiie
siècle le château de maison à maison
laffitte fait découvrir le rococo eva
bouillot bonjour bonjour vous êtes
responsable des activités culturelles du
château est ce qu'on peut faire un petit
point rapide sur ce qu'est le gros
copeaux oui alors le rococo c'est un
mouvement qui n'est en france au début
du xviiie siècle et sa particularité
c'est que ça va être de la fantaisie de
la rêverie un monde et un univers
enchanteur du château lui consacre une
exposition jusqu'au 22 mars
chante aisé pour un palais qu'est ce
qu'on nous trouve alors on y trouve
plusieurs décors en fait l'exposition et
en plusieurs étapes qui sont quasiment
comme des tableaux alors quand je dis
tableau c'est plutôt des décors des
décors de théâtre met en cause
voilà mais c'est également des ambiances
des univers qui sont traduit donc
typiquement le palais magique
le cabinet des miroirs ou encore le
bosquet des faits voilà c'est tout un
univers on rentre dans une ambiance de
fantaisie et d'illusions un vrai voyage
que vos équipes ont choisi de faire
prolonger avec un atelier qui complète
la visite exactement donc les familles
qui viennent qui s'inscrivent commence
par une visite pour vraiment appréhender
cet univers puisque finalement les gens
le connaissent pas nécessairement bien
ce style rococo rocaille donc ils
rentrent dans ce monde enchanteur fait
de surprises ils comprennent aussi que
les effets spéciaux existait avant
l'heure d'une autre manière
et donc après cela il rentre en atelier
donc la visite dure environ une
demi-heure aux trois quarts d'heure et
ensuite il ya vraiment une heure et
demie où on laisse place a créé sa
créativité
à partir de ce qu'on a vu justement et
là les enfants sont amenés à créer un
pop up
oui alors c'est une sorte de boîte pop
up avec des personnages qui vont sortir
d'un décor qu'ils vont eux-mêmes choisir
et créer et avec ce décor se rajoute le
miroir la création de miroirs et
d'illusions parce que c'est l'objectif
même du style rococo c'est de jouer de
s'amuser d'inventer un monde magique et
un monde féerique
j'imagine qu'il faut tester aussi parce
que les miroirs il faut les
possessionnais d'une bonne manière
exactement alors les miroirs c'est eux
qui créent de cette illusion de miroirs
qui crée aussi les décors avec toutes
ses arabesques que tous ces mouvements
qui choisissent aussi leurs couleurs
alors certains rendent complètement dans
cet univers doré et argenté
d'autres choisissent beaucoup plus de
couleurs et de fantaisie ça dépend de
l'univers de chacun et aussi de l'âge de
chacun l'âge l'atelier voulait réserver
surtout aux enfants à partir de huit ans
parce que je me dis il faut une certaine
dextérité pour la risée alors on
l'âge recommandé 7 à partir de 8 ans
bien évidemment reçoit des familles donc
des fratries
ce qui fait qu'il est aussi adapté avec
des moyens petit peu différent pour les
plus jeunes et pour ceux qui rateraient
les animations spéciales de ses vacances
vous proposer un autre type d'expérience
on peut fêter son anniversaire chez vous
pour mais oui c'est aussi magique de
pouvoir fêter son anniversaire dans un
château
ce sont des propositions que l'on fait
tout au long de l'année en général
plutôt le week end donc aussi sur
inscription et donc on a on est guidé
par une animatrice selon des thèmes
adaptés à chaque âge
et puis ensuite de sa de cela et bien on
a un espace qui nous est réservé pour
festoyer avec chandelle et bonbons
petits décors etc
les petites yvelinois bon de noter dans
leur agenda je pense qu'ils vont se
précipiter vers leurs parents merci eva
bouillot alors les animations au château
maison ont débuté cette semaine mais pas
d'inquiétude des dates vous sont
proposés jusqu'au 21 février
toutes les informations sont à retrouver
sur le site du château et pour être sûr
de pouvoir participer à l'atelier pensez
à vous inscrire
un autre château et à rambouillet cette
fois les équipes vous ont concocté une
chasse au trésor un trésor ancestrale
qui se transmet depuis des siècles entre
propriétaires du château vous serez dea
dans votre quête par une jeune
historienne elle découvre dans les
archives nationales
un vieux parchemin sans doute rédigé
dans les années 15 160 un moment à vivre
en famille du 17 au 22 février
l'animation se fait sur réservation
exclusivement c'est le moment de notre
page cinéma cette semaine c'est gaël
pinault qui vous invite dans les salles
du grenier à sel on les côtes
[Musique]
vous avez vu les résultats des oscars
parasite le film sud-coréen qui a
remporté le fils du mineur oscars et 4 4
oscars en tout c'est incroyable c'est
super parce que ce film là nous on adore
ou que parasite en version noir et blanc
au cinéma le grenier à sel c'est bientôt
nous avons aussi un événement japonais a
dont vous voulez vous parler c'est un
fils ya un film qui s'appelle dans un
jardin qu'on croyait à conduire et
éternelle c'est l'histoire d'une de deux
jeunes filles qui vont découvrir là
la cérémonie traditionnelle du thé c'est
l'occasion pour nous de faire dormir
avec des dégustations dégustation de thé
évidemment puisque c'est le sujet du
film mais aussi ce sera donc il y aura
un thé gratuit et il y aura aussi des
pâtisseries et des mini benneteau à
acheter donc ce sera ça à la toute fin
des vacances dimanche 23 février à 17h15
nous avons un autre évènement dont vous
voulez vous parler au mois de mars il ya
la journée du des droits des femmes et
nous le samedi 7 mars à 15 heures nous
diffuserons le film human qui est
coréalisé par la nature
arthus bertrand j'en profite pour vous
dire que vous pouvez réserver vos places
directement sur notre site nous avons
une billeterie en ligne
et nous avons une innovation aussi un
système s'appelle toi box qui permet aux
malentendants mal voyants sourds non
voyants de venir profiter du cinéma
comme comme doom comme nous tous si vous
voulez en savoir plus vous regardez sur
notre site où vous demander à l'accueil
au cinéma
[Musique]
découvrir les bases de l'improvisation
théâtrale pour la deuxième semaine des
vacances un projet propose un stage de
découverte
il est destiné aux adolescents âgés de
10 à 15 en une semaine d'apprentissage
avec en bonus le vendredi une nouveau
présentation d'une heure où les familles
et les amis sont attendus des précisions
des précisions du président de
l'association pendant cette semaine ils
vont pouvoir durant deux heures par jour
travailler des exercices d'improvisation
tout en s'amusant ils vont pouvoir
savoir mettre en scène des histoires
jouer des personnages interagir entre
eux créent aussi une cohésion entre dans
le groupe qui va être fort mais il reste
encore quelques places pour ceux qui
seraient tentés toutes les informations
sont à retrouver sur le site internet de
l'association
le stage se déroule à la clé des champs
de plaisir du 17 au 21 février
on quitte maintenant les yvelines pour
un spectacle à paris depuis le mois
d'octobre le metteur en scène alexandre
tournent à présent une adaptation du
roman pour enfants pinocchio de carlo
collodi
un spectacle interactif où la mise en
scène mêle plusieurs techniques
théâtrales un sujet signé de nos
confrères de via grand paris pinocchio
n'a pas toujours été ce gentil petit
pantin naïfs que nous connaissons tous
chez son créateur carlo collodi comme
dans cette adaptation d'alexandre
tourneur il est égoïste et désobéissant
un véritable polisson qui se lancent
dans des aventures périlleuses
et quoi de plus ingénieux que de mêler
magie marionnettes masques et théâtre
d'ombrés pour raconter et mettre en
scène les péripéties de pinocchio on a
utilisé toutes ces techniques théâtrales
pour pouvoir non seulement les exploiter
mais aussi rendre les images du bouquin
visible on y retrouve un chat un renard
on y retrouve un oiseau sur lequel
pinocchio va voler on y retrouve
énormément de choses et donc il faut
réussir à adapter sa au théâtre or le
seul moyen de l'adapter c ou par l'image
ou alors de trouver des petits
subterfuges et qu'ils puissent aussi
intéresser les enfants c'est pour ça
qu'on a utilisé toutes ces techniques
théâtrales des techniques théâtrales qui
donne l'impression de voir plusieurs
comédiens sur scène alors qu'en réalité
ils ne sont que deux
par le biais des masques par le biais
des costumes on arrive déjà incarné
plusieurs personnages donc ce qui est
assez agréable pour un comédien
c'était aussi un challenge de monter une
pièce à plusieurs personnages qu'avec
deux personnes sans qu'on sente que ce
soit deux personnes qui sont sur scène
mais qu'on ait l'impression qu'ils aient
un panel de
personnage tout au long de ses aventures
pinocchio n'est pas seul
le public est là pour le guider et pour
l'aider à prendre des décisions
importantes et pour le metteur en scène
l'aspect pédagogique est primordial le
but étant que cette interaction ne soit
qu'un apprentissage c'est à dire que
vont guider pinocchio et que les enfants
par eux mêmes décident de ce qui est
juste de ce que devrait faire pinocchio
et c'est ça qui est assez intéressant
cette tradition et izon cette conscience
déjà de ce qui est important de faire
est important de ne pas faire pinocchio
deviendra-t-il un vrai petit garçon ou
restera-t-il une marionnette avis vous
avez jusqu'au 29 février 2020 pour
décider de son sort
c'est la fin de ce cette chute loisirs
vous pouvez revoir cette émission en
replay sur notre site internet et
applications mobiles
on se retrouve jeudi prochain à 18h30
pour de nouvelles idées sorties
[Musique]
ouais